GUS GOSTYLA: Welcome, everyone.
They put us back in the
corner, because they
knew we were the loose cannons.
So we're way in the back.
Hope you're woken
up from your lunch.
Welcome, everyone.
Thanks for coming today.
I'm Gus Gostyla, and I
look after cultivating
our relationships with the
venture capital and startup
community on behalf of
Google and Android, Google
Play and Android.
And my colleague
is Ellie Powers,
who will take the second half,
who leads our developer product
team here.
The two of us have been
spending a lot of time
with startups this year.
So I'd like to ask how many
people work at startups
who are in the crowd.
Get a show of hands.
Awesome.
Like, it's less than 100
people kind of companies.
That's great.
You're in the right place.
So we're here to talk
to you about how many of
you are succeeding
on Google Play,
and why more and more
are launching on Android
and SIM shipping your apps.
And to start, you could say
this is a bit of a passion
area for me personally.
I spent a good chunk of my
career at mobile startups.
Most recently ones like
Inkling and Flipboard.
And now I get to sit on
the other side of the fence
where my team is
focused exclusively
on helping startups
succeed and making it
feel like less of a black art.
So while the team is new,
in just the last few months
it's already become
obvious to Ellie and myself
that there are some
recurring themes
we hear from startups
that come to Android.
And so we'd like to discuss
those with you here.
Specifically, we broke
the recurring themes
down into three
buckets that we would
label as follows-- Reach, the
Next Billion, and Iteration.
And we'll spend
our time drilling
down on how to get
the most out of those.
And we'll also share
three case studies
of startups who are really
representing those themes well
and demonstrating best
practices in these areas.
So let's get started with
Reach and the First Billion
before we go on to
the Next Billion.
You've probably heard
of Benedict Evans
over at Andreessen Horowitz.
He's one of my personal
favorite mobile pundits
in the mobile tech world.
And he's prolific with his
dispatches on subject of mobile
eating the world.
So a few months ago
he said this-- mobile
is the first universal
tech product.
And he was referring to the
data on the following slide.
And he points out
some projections
from various
sources, specifically
global population on the left
of nearly 8 billion people
projected in 2020.
And the population of people
over 16 years old at 6 billion.
And finally, smartphones
projected at 5 billion in 2020,
way further on the left.
And the expected growth
you can see in purple
between 2015 and 2020.
His point is, and my
point is, that smartphones
are starting to get close
to nearly reaching everyone
on the planet.
And that's kind of a big deal.
It's pretty profound
and non-trivial when
you consider how
little effort is
required to make
and sell products
that reach nearly everyone.
And there's never really
been a similar kind
of product or platform.
Sure, Coca-Cola, bicycles, and
refrigerators are neat too,
and they have great reach.
But they're not quite the
same democratizing platforms
for allowing the world
to communicate, transact,
and disseminate information
in quite the same way.
So now when we
think about Android
and how it factors into
that global reach, last year
Android crossed a
pretty huge threshold
with over a billion devices
shipped around the world.
And now you can see us logging
in 1.4 billion 30-day actives.
And we've seen 1.5
million Android devices
being activated daily.
And the continued platform
momentum of 400 OEMs
and 500 operators
on the platform.
It's pretty incredible
that Play was launched just
over four years ago.
While Android is expanding
the footprint of device
availability, Play is helping
developers build businesses
across the globe.
And it's growing pretty
fast in its own right.
Way back when I
was in your shoes,
back at mobile app startups
and Android was just
getting started, in the echo
chamber here in the Valley
it was still kind of
fashionable to pick on Android
and say it lacked billion
dollar startup success stories.
And then something
funny happened.
Companies like WhatsApp and
Uber, Line King, Flipkart,
Spotify, Supercell
started sprouting up
in these insane
growth trajectories,
and have become massive global
brands in their own right.
Ask any of those
companies now if Android
is important to their business.
And I think they'll agree.
My point is this-- my experience
at startups made it clear
that a founder's
job is fundamentally
to challenge the
status quo thinking,
and observe what is
changing around you.
Ask yourself what you know
to be true in the future,
and execute relentlessly
on your vision.
So in that light,
I'd ask you all
to take a hard look
at Android when you're
getting started
on your next idea,
and consider how Reach
might factor heavily
in your startup's
growth objectives.
Of course, many of you have
already asked these questions.
And that's why
you're here today.
And so keep plugging
away on Android.
That's awesome.
Once you've made your
Android platform decision,
what should you do next to
realize the full benefits
of smartphone reach?
Well, there's a couple things
you need to know to get there.
In our experience, these
are the first few things
you should be thinking about.
Building for reach.
So let's begin with material.
The last session was
all about material.
And there was code on
slides and all that stuff.
We're not going to
do that here today.
But I did want to
point this one out,
because maybe it's not
immediately obvious,
but material has been
crucial for startups
trying to attain reach.
And in that material offers
one universal language
for navigation and interaction
that is becoming second nature
for Android users.
And I myself, having
come from those startups,
I was skeptical about
material when they first
told me about it, and
felt like our apps should
look the same across all
platforms and that kind
of thing.
But basically what I've learned
is that by using material,
you already have
a huge head start
on using a design that
most of those billion
plus users around the
world already understand,
and in a way that is so
prevalent that it's now
making its way onto
other platforms, as well.
As a result,
developers are seeing
leaps in engagement
and conversion rates
across the board when
they implement it.
And you can see some of
the great examples here.
Apps like Fablic,
Musicmatch, Trello
seeing some notable increases
in time and activity
in their apps.
And so yes, material is cool.
But also think from
the business side
about it being this common
language that everybody gets.
While startups told us material
design was cool when we first
announced it, you also told
us that it was a little hard
to know where to get
started, and that you
wanted more resources to make
building material apps easier.
And so we totally heard you.
And over the past
few years we've
been rolling out a
bunch of new resources
that you can find at
design.google.com.
I won't go into all the
details of all these things
here, given the last
presentation probably
went into great depth there.
But that's a hub you can
go find resources from.
Another thing a lot
of startups worry
about when they're approaching
Android for the first time
is device compatibility.
Last year at Google I/O we
announced Cloud Test lab
and Beta.
And this year we're taking
the training wheels off
and moving it into Firebase.
And as you'd expect,
Firebase test lab
is integrated with
many different tools.
So you can bring it into
your workflow easily.
I'm sure some of you
have probably been
to other sessions
on Firebase already.
And I would urge
you as a startup
to really think about this
platform, because it's
got so many different
things in it
wrapped up into
one great package,
whereas companies that
are a little further along
tend to specialize in
the tools they use.
So Firebase is especially
well-suited to startups
who are just figuring it out.
In Google Play, all
alpha and beta apps
are tested against a
representative range of devices
of profiles in the cloud.
This test is
completely automated.
So you don't need to
write test scripts.
You can detect where there
are any obvious issues
on these devices before rolling
out your app to all users.
And you can now enable this
from within the dev console.
The best part of the
base level of this
is that it's totally
free, which is awesome.
After trying the pre-launch
report in the death console,
the next thing
developers say they
want is to run exactly
the set of tasks they want
on a specific set of devices.
And they'll be a
way to do that too.
You'll be able to write
custom test scripts
and run them on physical or
virtual devices you choose.
And you can even do that
from Android Studio,
your other continuous
integration systems.
Once you have a good sense
that your product is working,
another great way
to grow reach is
to obviously expand to
other countries, globally.
You'll need to think
about localizing your app
and your Play Store listing.
From within the dev
console, we provide
tools and recommendations
to help you translate
your app across global markets.
Take Netflix, for example.
They recently had a lot of press
about globalizing their app.
And you know, they didn't just
translate their title and app
description, but also
made sure screenshots
and video trailers accurately
represented the app
in all markets.
Pricing.
Also an area you
want to consider
to make sure your
price translates
for local expectations,
making sure your price doesn't
look like it's like
$1.73, like here.
Or the cultural
equivalent of that,
which differs by country,
what the sort of standards
are around pricing.
And so we help you figure
that out automatically.
For example, we saw 2x lift.
You can see here in
Japan for those that
rounded to the nearest yen.
So this was pretty cool.
So now that you've heard
more about tactical advice
on extracting benefits
of reach out of Android,
let's hear more from
a startup developer
who has been capitalizing on
some of those opportunities.
WeVideo is a startup right
here in our backyard,
and has some relevant
experience to share.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-WeVideo was founded
with the vision
of making digital storytelling
and video creation
accessible to anyone, anywhere.
When we first
started in Android,
we clearly saw that there
wasn't a compelling application
for a video creation.
Combine that with the fast
growth of Android platforms,
we decided to go Android first.
Since then, the majority
of our investment
in smartphone development
has been on Android.
What separates us from other
applications on Android
is that we give you the full
capability of the device
in our application.
You're able to take
different clips, trim them.
And we're able to do
that because the Android
platform gave us access
to the open GL there,
which allowed us to do real
time rendering and previewing.
Since the launch of
our new application,
mobile monetization has
done very well for us.
Our revenue on Android has
doubled every two months.
Almost 85% of our
users are on Android.
We'd launch a
material design, we
decided to redo the application
and redo the user experience,
and take it up to
the next level.
-Many of the material
design concepts
really resonated with us.
We were really able to create
a delightful experience
for our users.
And as a result, we saw 100%
increase in user engagement.
Being able to reply to
reviews is a great feature.
Every day we go through
every single review
and analyze the data
that's coming in.
And most importantly,
if there's somebody
who's having a problem,
we can help right away.
And it's such a
good feeling when
you can see someone who gave you
one star review converting that
to four or five stars.
We love running experiments
on the Play Store.
For example, just recently
we updated our screen shots
with the colors, the text, and
we saw increase in conversion
up to 50%.
Making the app available
in different languages
is critical for you to
succeed in global market.
We saw increase in our installs
up 200% in some regions
after we revised our app and
a Play Store descriptions.
Recently, we revisited our
purchasing flow in the app.
We wanted to see if we
could convert more people
to buy our premium products.
We decided to change colors
of the background, font size
way out of the elements.
We were able to deploy
quickly and trade just
within a few days.
And we say an increase up to
60% in the conversion rate.
-The Android platform has
been a great platform for us
to iterate through
our applications.
With the fast app publishing
process, Play Store listing
experiments,
feedback from users,
and monetization
using Google Wallet,
this has led to a tremendous
increase in success
with installs and revenue.
[END PLAYBACK]
GUS GOSTYLA: Cool.
So we talked a little bit about
Reach in the last billion.
So let's talk about getting
to the next billion.
That will likely come
online for the first time
on mobile in emerging markets.
In a sense, we've been spoiled
by tech in the developed world.
And while we were validating
our cars, Ubering around town,
ordering dinner delivery, and
frolicking with the spirit
guide butcher in the
BlackRock desert,
it's easy to forget that
phones being purchased
in the developing world could
be somebody's first computer,
first source of books,
education, health
advice, access to e-commerce,
news, microfinance,
or entrepreneurial inspiration.
While it might feel like
these markets are behind,
leap-frogging
opportunities are being
created, as some are
learning to transact globally
for the first time on
mobile, not desktop.
And hence their behavior
is mobile first by default.
Fred Wilson at Union
Square Ventures
recently called out
this opportunity
in a blog post called The Second
Smartphone Revolution, where
he was specifically referencing
the transformational mobile
impact in emerging markets.
He asked whether the
winners in the next phase
would come from Silicon Valley
or from the local developing
world.
It's up to you to find out.
But I'm incredibly excited to
see how both sets of founders
go and solve some of the
incredible new challenges
in emerging markets
with their apps.
Coincidentally, he too
referenced Benedict Evans
in that article, here who
says, "Yes, everyone."
And points out that the
incredible reach of mobile
as a percentage of coverage
of the African population
is surpassing even grid
electricity and soon,
clean water.
He also points out
the role of Android
and its affordability,
which helps
drive this transformational
reach and access.
Consider that while the
developed world has created
a lot of solutions for
first world problems,
and is closer to reaching
device saturation,
there is a lot of blank space
for expansion in the developing
world where the next
billion will come from,
and where the problems outside
of our little echo chamber
can be far more profound
and life-changing to solve.
In other words, a whole
new wave of innovation
is just beginning, not
just at the level of luxury
and convenience,
but from the bottom
of Maslow's hierarchy of
needs, all the way to the top.
Putting that back in context
of reach to real people,
the projections are that
1.2 billion new users
will come online in
emerging markets by 2018.
So what can you do to reach
them with your new ideas?
First understand some
of the constraints
and best practices designed for.
We've done a lot of
talking here this week
about the next billion.
But obviously, the
slower data connections,
users that pay as they go,
paying closer attention
to their consumption,
disconnected
scenarios and opportunities
for offline modes
and caching, low end devices
with different lower storage
and battery specs
mean you want to keep
APK updates, [INAUDIBLE] small,
and other notable things.
Which brings me to some things
we have done recently with Play
to eat our own dog food and
develop solutions to some
of these challenges ourselves.
Specifically, we've been
working to automatically make
the store more efficient for
you, given the constraints I
just shared.
First, we've been improving our
identification and promotion
of locally relevant apps.
If your app meets the
needs of emerging markets,
and for example, works
well on slow connections,
supports local languages, we'll
make sure users find your app.
Second, we've been working
to make the store more data
efficient.
So Google Play is investing
in making updates smaller.
As you can see here,
when you update your app,
Play computes the difference
from the older version.
We've also updated the story UI
to show the delta in size that
needs to be downloaded
by the user,
instead of the entire app size.
Updates can be really small.
And so this helps users get
less nervous about the size
of the download.
Last but not least, payments.
In the last 12 months, we
enabled 61 new forms of payment
in 32 markets, which means that
400 million people have access
to a new form of payment.
Just to zoom in on one
example of a roll out of DCB--
direct carrier billing.
In Indonesia, you can see the
crazy inflection point here
where we rolled
it out represents
a 4x increase in buyer growth.
We've seen very similar
results in other countries
like Turkey, Saudi
Arabia, and the UAE.
We recommend running
promotions in your apps
to get a share of
that excitement
when we launch new payment
support in those countries.
As I mentioned, you can sell
your app in 130 countries.
Not surprisingly, the more
locally relevant payment
methods we add, the more
users become buyers.
And you can see some of
the specific uplift metrics
here, most notably 30%
year over year growth
in developer's
international sales,
and some big movements here in
various markets like Germany,
Russia, and in Hong Kong.
Purchasing behavior
in particular
varies significantly
between markets.
So to provide developers
with more flexibility,
we have worked to adapt
Google Play pricing
options to better suit local
purchasing power parity levels,
and make content
more accessible.
Following a successful pilot
in India earlier this year,
earlier this year,
today developers
have the option to reduce the
price of their premium titles
and in-app products
in 17 more countries
to new minimum thresholds like
the ones you can see here.
In this example, you can see
the impact of lower prices
more in line with
local markets resulted
in 136% increase in
spike in orders, which
overcame the drop
in price with volume
for an overall game
of 27% in revenue.
So you're absolutely
reaching more people
and still making more money.
So with that, I
hope you're starting
to get the sense of this
theme of how relentlessly
our teams are
working to pass along
big improvements
to the platform,
and how passionate we are about
investing in our developer
community.
I'd like to transition
into another startup story.
This time, Sendy based
in Kenya, solving
for challenges of local
delivery and very crowded cities
like Nairobi.
Go ahead and play.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Sendy is a Kenyan company.
We connect customers
and logistics providers.
What we've done
differently is figuring out
the last minute logistics,
which is a problem in most
developing countries.
I mean, we don't have
things like addresses here.
-Being able to use technology
to solve a problem that really
nobody has been able
to solve in this region
is probably the
most exciting beat.
Sendy has two Android
apps, one for the customers
and one for the drivers.
The great thing
about Sendy is you're
able to drop pins for your
pickup and dropoff locations.
So it's easier for you
to identify it on a map
rather than entering
an actual address.
We went to Android because the
majority of the users in Kenya,
East Africa, has Android
phones, and the fact
that the process
of actually doing
that continuous
deployment to customers
is much faster than
other platforms.
As a startup that is
constantly trying new things,
we tend to dole
out features a lot.
Cool feature in the
Google K developer console
is the alpha meter
testing groups.
We normally roll out our
new versions of the app
to groups that help us test and
get as many bugs as possible
before the app goes
into final release.
Most people love
it when the UI flow
is as easy to use as possible.
Material design offers a very
simple language for people
to understand on a phone that
most Kenyans appreciate it.
When developing apps
for the Kenyan market,
there are certain things
that you need to consider.
You need to make sure
that your APK size is not
too large, because
most people don't
have a lot of storage space.
You also need to check
the amount of data
your app is using,
because people
are very sensitive of the
amount of data they use.
Battery usage is
also very important.
People don't have the luxury
of plugging in their phones
all the time.
-One of the key things
must be building trust
among your users.
So one of the things
we did in the beginning
is provide free
delivery to customers.
The other way of building
trust is making sure
that we keep the
customer [INAUDIBLE]
know where the driver is
through our Android app.
-The way we've utilized
Google Play Developer
Console to establish
trust is that first we
make sure that our ratings
on the Play Store are high.
We also rely on statistics
such as the number
of crashes per app version.
That is very helpful
for me as a developer
to know what bugs I
should escalate and fix
as quickly as possible.
-I think integrating local
payments is very, very
key as well to this access of
customers using your product.
Over 80% of our customers
pay for services
using mobile money.
We have been seeing financial
growth within the company.
We've gone from a team
of three to now a team
of about 23 people.
-Being able not only to have
an impact to the end user,
but also to the drivers
in our platform.
So giving them an
income that they weren't
able to earn a few
months ago is really
something that is touching
for me as a person.
I feel that we are driving the
economy in the littlest way
possible.
But we're still
driving the economy,
which is enough for me.
[END PLAYBACK]
GUS GOSTYLA: So cool.
I just love-- you
know, we get so
wrapped up in the
stuff in our backyard
here in Silicon Valley.
And it's awesome to see startups
all over the world solving
very diverse sets of problems.
And I just see that there's
so much more opportunity there
for the next phase.
If the next billion in emerging
markets is of strong interest
to you, I also encourage
you to stick around
for the next session, which will
go into detail on initiatives
and progress we are making
to open up those markets.
Next up is Ellie, who you might
recognize from the Keynote
on Instant Apps yesterday, and
then Play stuff this morning.
And Ellie, it's all yours.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: Thanks
very much, Gus.
So one of the most
exciting things
that Gus alluded to
a little bit earlier
that my team has
been doing this year
is we make Google
Play and the developer
console for so many different
types of developers, right?
Big companies.
Small companies.
Countries here in Mountain
View, countries in Kenya,
all sorts of
different developers.
And the new emphasis we really
put on in this past year
was to work with
startups specifically.
And so Gus' team has had a
big outreach program where
we try to go and actually
meet with more startups
like all of you to understand
what information do you need
to be successful,
and also for my team,
how can we go and
refine the products
that we offer to all of you.
And so what I'm here
to talk about today
is basically this
idea of iteration.
Right?
And here at Google we
got really, I guess,
famous for having Gmail
as a beta for a long time.
We didn't know
what color to make
the links on Google
Search a decade ago,
so we ran experiments.
We love to be data-driven.
We love to iterate.
We love to try new things, but
also get a lot of user feedback
in order to improve.
And we think that that's
something that even now
that we're a big company
that we have in common
with a lot of startups.
And so we want to make it
really possible for all of you
to be able to do
the same things,
to be able to gather user
feedback really easily,
which as you know, is so
critical in the early days
of your company, and also to
be able to try new things,
iterate rapidly, and be able
get them out for users again.
So we really want to
empower all of you.
And so what we're
going to do is to go
through a couple of the
different products--
some of them were mentioned
in some of the videos
before-- to really talk about
what you should know about
as a startup.
And the reason we're giving this
talk is we have a lot of people
that we run into at
different startup events.
And they go, beta testing,
I never even heard of that.
If only I had known.
Or really, I can reply
to my user's reviews?
If only I had known.
And so our goal today is to
try to make sure all of you
here are aware of the toolkit
that we offer on Google Play.
So Gus actually introduced
me to this saying recently.
"If you want to
go fast, go alone.
But if you want to
go far, go together."
And what I really like about
this is that what we want to do
is to go it with you, and
to help you go faster.
And we hope that through
working with Google Play,
you'll be able to go together,
and also go twice as fast.
So we're going to talk about
four different types of tools
that are the most
unique things that we
have to offer developers,
especially startups,
on Google Play.
So let's get started.
So Google Play works a little
bit differently, right?
And I think one of
the things that people
need to know, especially if
they've been on other app
platforms before, is
Google Play actually
has some things that are a
little bit different about it.
So the earlier in your
life you can find out
about all the different
features that we have,
that may actually
change how you want
to move through your
product development cycle.
So the first thing
that's important to know
is that for any of you who
have an app on Google Play--
does anyone have an app on
Google Play today, by the way?
OK.
Does anyone have an app
that's still in Stealth mode,
or not on Google Play yet?
A couple folks.
So we're hoping to reach
you a little bit earlier.
So the most important
thing for you to know
is that you can publish your
app on Play any time you want.
And developers tell
us year after year
that's one of the most
important things to them
is that all of you are
in control about when
you can publish your app.
There is no big wait
or anything like that.
And the next thing that
you want to think about
after that is this idea of beta
testing and staged rollouts.
So at Google we have an app.
We have lots of apps.
And when we release
them, we don't
want to put them out there
to all the users with just
the initial version.
Right?
What we want to do is
to kind of roll them out
more progressively and to
get feedback along the way.
So these two
tools-- beta testing
and staged rollouts--
are unique tools on Play
that you can use to make
sure that you get a really
high quality result,
and also kind of take
control of your rollout.
And so we want to walk
you through how this is.
And what we see from a lot of
our most successful developers
is they actually use
these products every day--
the beta testing and
the staged rollouts.
So for example, at
Google, with but basically
every app update we rollout,
we use staged rollouts.
And we think that
even startups can
benefit from these
sorts of things as well.
We see when you use
these practices,
you can end up with a much
higher quality result,
a higher quality app, and a
much better business return,
as well.
So let's start by talking
about beta testing.
Is anyone here
running a beta test,
or ever run one in the past?
That's awesome.
So we actually see with some
of our most popular apps--
the top 1,000 apps on
Google Play-- 60% of them
are running a beta
test right now.
And so if you haven't
tried a beta test before,
here's basically the idea.
You can distribute your
app to a subset of users.
And then you can get
feedback earlier,
rather than just
launching it to everyone.
With beta testing,
what's important
here is users actually
need to opt in and say yes,
I want to be a tester.
And so this can be
really important,
because it's not going
to be a completely
representative sample.
But it will be kind of
self-selecting power users--
people who are willing
to put up with bugs,
and ideally also
give you feedback
about how you need to improve.
So you can test two
different versions.
We call them alpha and beta.
You can view stats about them.
And it's a great
thing to do before you
rollout in production.
So let's talk about some of
the unique features here.
So users who are in a beta
or alpha test cannot actually
leave you a review.
So this is important.
You don't want them
to leak anything
or to hurt your star rating.
That won't happen.
If someone's opted
in to be a tester,
they can't give you reviews.
So we want to go
through a couple
of the pieces of feedback
we've gotten over the years
to clear up any misconceptions
that might be out there.
So the most common
thing we heard from you
after we rolled out beta
testing was, OK, this is cool.
But I want to make it a
lot easier to manage who's
in and out of my beta test.
So last year we
announced something
called open and closed betas.
So if you want to allow
anyone to join your beta,
you can create what's
called an open beta test.
This way you'll just be
able to let anyone join.
And actually as of
this week, now users
can opt-in directly
to your open beta test
on your page in the Play Store.
Your second option,
if you still want
to keep it in stealth
mode, is to do
what we call a closed beta.
So in addition to Google
Groups and Google+ communities,
you can also specify a
list of email addresses.
So that allows you to control
only these people get access
to my alpha or beta test.
So by the way, if you
haven't checked out yet,
like that's what
it's actually going
to look like in the Play Store.
So for all of you who have
a beta test, an open beta
on Play, go check it out.
And then you may want to update
some of your documentation
to your beta testers
about how they can opt-in.
And we think this will
make it a lot easier.
And also for anyone who
already has your app installed,
if they happen to peruse your
page in the Play store again,
they might see this.
And it will make it a
lot easier for you to get
more folks in your betas.
Now we mentioned earlier that
when people are in a beta,
they can't leave
you a review, right?
Super important.
And for the whole time that
beta testing's been out there,
developers can collect
feedback from users
in a whole range of ways.
Some people put some sort
of a form in the app itself.
Others provide an email address
for collecting feedback.
Other people have
a discussion forum.
And we added one new
option this week,
which is that users will be able
to give you private feedback
through the Play Store.
So they go to the Play Store.
And it's in the same place where
they would be leaving a review.
But it's actually
private feedback.
So you can see here that
this user in the Play Store
has provided private
feedback to the developer.
And when you go into
the developer console,
you'll be able to see the
private beta feedback there as
well.
And again, this is
not shown publicly.
It does not affect your
app's rating in any way.
So back to the earlier point
about going fast and going
together.
We announced earlier this
week something that we're
calling Early Access.
And what this is this is a
special place in the Play Store
where users, early
adopter users, who
want to try out the
latest and greatest stuff
can go to see apps that
are actually in beta.
And the reason we
launched this was we
heard from a lot
of startups, wow.
Beta testing sounds great.
I'd love to get a bunch
of people giving me
early feedback on my app.
But I'm a startup.
I don't even have many users.
How could I possibly grow
a group of beta testers?
So what we decided
to do was to identify
some of the most exciting
apps that are out there, many
of them from startups.
And all of them haven't
really been made publicly
available on Google Play yet.
So we handpicked them so
that this way users can
go there and be sure
that they're finding out
about really cool stuff
that's actually still working
pretty well, but be able to get
that feedback to developers,
get developers like you
a bit more exposure,
and to help you be able
to iterate more quickly
and improve your products.
And this is a great
way that we have
a huge reach in the Play store.
And we're trying
to put this to work
for you to help you find
early testers for your apps
and get the feedback that
you folks need to improve
and get ready for
a broader launch.
OK.
And then, OK.
So you have your app.
You did a beta test.
You got some feedback.
It's looking pretty good.
And you're ready to roll out.
So you roll out to everybody.
And then once you've done
that, the next time you
want to roll out
a new version, you
can still beta test your
newer versions as well.
But when you're ready to
put new updates to your app
out to everybody,
you'll probably
want to do what we do
at Google, and what
we see a lot of our
top partners do,
which is doing a staged rollout.
So I may not want to roll
out to everyone on day one.
Maybe I just want
to start with 10%.
Then I'll monitor the
reviews that I'm getting.
Maybe I'll use
Firebase to monitor
the crashes that are coming in.
I'll see how it's doing.
And if I feel confident,
20%, 30%, 50%, and then I'll
roll it out to everyone.
And here if there's a major
bug, or if people just really
don't like the new color scheme
my designer came up with,
I can halt the rollout.
I can immediately upload a
new version if I need to.
And then other people who
didn't have the new version
yet won't be affected by
any negative issues that
were in my latest update.
One thing to keep
in mind, though,
when you are in
a staged rollout,
people can leave reviews.
So be sure it is good
before you start that.
So another trend we've
seen with developers
is just the amount of
time that all of you
spend managing your
Play Store reviews.
So we would talk to developers.
And they would say, look.
The more users I get,
the more reviews I get.
And it's great.
But I have to have
someone sit there
and read them all the time, and
then try to have that person,
you know, summarize
back to the team
to understand what are users
like, what are they not like,
what should we do next.
And so over the
years, we've been
updating what we have to make
it easier for you to manage.
So one of the unique
things we have
is that you're
actually able to reply
to reviews on the Play Store.
Has anyone done
that, by the way?
Anyone replied to a
review on the Play Store?
Has anyone thought about
it but not done it yet?
Yeah.
It's worth considering.
We definitely see that users
who actually update their review
after receiving a
reply are actually
increasing their review
on average by 0.7 stars.
So it's definitely a good
thing to think about.
So that exists.
We've had search on the reviews,
a whole range of graphs.
We recently rolled out
email notifications
so that if someone updates their
review again, you can find out.
So all of these
things are to try
to make reviews more friendly
to help you be able to dive
into what's happening
with your reviews
and how you can
manage them better.
Because every app that you
get, and every app review
that you get in the
Play store is really
an opportunity to have
a one-on-one interaction
with a customer.
And I know all of you care about
your users as much as we do.
And so having those tools
to be able to talk to them
or understand what's going
on can be so important.
So this year what we're
just rolling out now,
and we announced
at I/O this week,
is automated ways to be able
to extract more information out
of the reviews for you.
Because developers
would tell us,
well, I have to have
someone sit there
and go through literally
hundreds of reviews.
Right?
Not that exciting.
And then how does that
person report back?
So we've taken our machine
learning technologies,
and we're able to
automatically summarize them.
So we're doing a couple things.
First of all, there's
certain topics
that are common across all apps
and we see coming up in reviews
all the time.
Things like design,
usability, apps stability.
And so what we're
doing is automatically
identifying any reviews that
cite those sorts of factors.
Right.
Are people talking
about your app crashing?
You know, we'll be able
to surface that to you
so you can just dive in and
see all the reviews that are
related to, let's say, crashes.
Or maybe you do a great
new material design layout.
You can look at all the
feedback about design
to see if users are
liking your new layout.
And then a lot of
developers have asked
us, well, are my reviews good?
Does my app measure up?
How do I compare to my peers?
And so since we're able
to come look at your app
across these common topics
that happen to all apps,
we can now actually tell
you how your app's reviews
in that particular subject
compare to similar apps.
So for example, are more people
mentioning crashes in your app
compared to similar apps?
Are more people mentioning
design, for example?
And then you can also
see what the impact
will be on your rating.
So for example, we
see a lot of people
if they have a lot of crashes
that users are mentioning,
that will be dragging
their review down.
Usually if there's
crashes, it's more
of a one star type of rating.
But maybe a lot of people
love your new design.
And you can see that that's
having a positive impact
and pulling your rating up.
And so that can be really
helpful so you can understand,
if I want to get my
rating up there, what
are the aspects that I'm
going to need to address.
All right.
I want to go back one.
OK.
I can't.
But the other thing I wanted
to mention about it is-- oh.
That's interesting.
It was magic.
So the other thing I wanted
to mention about it too
is that in addition to
these common topics,
your app probably has unique
features about it, right?
Maybe you have a racing game.
And you have different
types of cars.
Maybe you have a fitness app.
And you have features like
pre-programmed workouts,
or calorie counters, or
instructional videos.
And so these unique
features of your app,
we'll also pull them out
with our machine learning
and natural processing as well.
So this way you
can also see, OK,
if I launched a new feature,
like a new type of car
in my racing game, how often
is that being mentioned?
And then more importantly,
is that correlated
with an increase or
decrease in my app's rating?
So by looking at all
these things together,
we want to just make
it easier for you
to see at a glance what people
are saying about your app,
and also to help you zoom in.
We hear all the time from
startups, I have so much to do.
I'm overwhelmed with data.
Like, just tell me
what I should work on.
And so we would love to
hear feedback and understand
if these new reports are
helping you zoom in on what
it is that you need to do next.
OK.
So you have an app.
You beta tested it.
Your reviews are
looking pretty good.
And now what you want to do
is start to go bigger, right?
And so you want to
build your audience.
So what we do on Google Play is
we launched the store listing
experiments feature last year.
And this is a great way to be
able to optimize your store
listing.
You want to know that
it's working well.
So what we do at Google
is we test everything.
And we wanted to roll this
out to you guys as well.
So here are some best
practices with it.
You want to have a hypothesis.
You know, is it that
your hypothesis is
that, your fitness app, people
really like the training video
capability.
So you want to emphasize
that, or it's something else.
And then what you
want to do is to be
able to run your
different experiments,
see what the results are, run
it all the way to the end.
And then a great
thing about startups
is, if your brand isn't
already well-established,
you can be pretty bold
in which what you're
willing to experiment on.
Right?
A totally new icon?
Go for it.
The big changes are what's going
to get you the biggest payoff.
So here's an
example of how Rovio
was able to use a
series of experiments
to get up to a pretty
significant increase.
By running these
experiments, they
had a double digit improvement
in their conversion rate
on Play.
And they had a lot
of great things
to say about how it
impacted their business.
So that brings us to Aviary.
They are a startup in New York.
They were acquired
by Adobe in 2004.
And they've been using
some of the iteration tools
that we just discussed.
Let's take a look at this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-I'm Avi Muchnick.
I'm one of the
co-founders of Aviary.
There are thousands of photo
editing apps out there.
We we've always looked to do
is to simplify the experience
for the end user.
We want something that no matter
what your background in tech
is, you can just
literally pick it up,
and in less than six
seconds, understand
how to use it, and make
your photos look great.
One of the most amazing things
about the Android platform
is our communication
with our users.
It's not really us responding
to bug reports that we see.
It's really this
ongoing two-way dialogue
we have with people,
both through beta tests,
and also through
ratings reviews.
We can see things as they're
happening in real time.
We can talk with our
community to find out
what features they like
and what they don't like,
and what things they would
love to see in the app
that we haven't even
thought of, and implement
that in real time.
-Working with the
Android dev console
has been amazing compared to
other platforms in particular.
With Android, we are able
to see metrics about them.
We're able to
search through them.
We're able to actually
respond to users.
With the new tools, I
would say that we're
able to identify
issues twice as fast.
It makes it easy for us to
search through the reviews,
contact users when we need to,
get more information from them.
And just in general,
it has saved me
a tremendous amount of time,
anywhere between 5 to 10 hours
a week.
-Android in general is hugely
impactful to the Aviary team.
It's over 2/3 of our user base.
We use Search Within
Reviews every day.
We use it to validate
new features.
For example, we
recently released
a new discover feature.
We'll search
Discover to see what
users are saying about that,
and let us know if they like it,
or if there are
problems with it.
And that helps us make
product decisions.
The ratings and reviews feature
has been immensely impactful.
Having the ability to quickly
drill into issues by device,
by app version, by
Android version,
and then also anecdotally sift
through what users are saying
and the actual
words they're using
is pretty unique
to the platform.
And it helps us develop
much more quickly.
-Responding to users
in the dev console
has been immensely
impactful for us.
For instance, recently
we released a version
that I resolved a pretty
major bug that was
affecting many of our users.
I went into the dev
console, responded
to all of the people who
were experiencing the bug,
and about 50% of them actually
went back and ended up
updating the review.
-One of the things I love
about building for the Android
platform is how quickly we
can test and deploy on it.
We have this fantastic
beta community on Android
that can test out new features.
And that helps us
identify bugs, or what
features they like or don't
like, much more quickly.
-Being able to do that allows
us to iterate two to three times
faster on Android compared
to other platforms, which is
hugely impactful for our app.
Photo Editor by
Aviary is meant to be
a dead simple but powerful
photo editing tool.
Having that dialogue
with our users
through the tools the Developer
Console and the Play Store
gives us, we're able
to iterate much faster
and deliver on an easy
simple interface, which
is really powerful for us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ELLIE POWERS: All right.
Thank you very much.
It's been great talking
with all of you.
And we're really
excited to see what
comes up next for all of you.
I hope also all of you will
download the Play console
app on Google Play.
And keep giving us
your feedback about how
we can get better for startups.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]